what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to geek culture explain
where i will make you an expert in all
things geek culture related in 10
minutes or less and this
is our final episode of hype train for
falcon and the winter soldier
here's the thing right the show was it
was it was a fun show it was a good show
it just didn't quite have
the pizzazz and the mystery surrounding
wand division and that's not a bad thing
they're designed to be two distinctly
different shows i will say this
i think we really know what's going on
with val now right like here's a crazy
thing right here's a crazy thing about
this val was a character they just kind
of threw in there and she just appeared
and that was it right i think val's
gonna have a role in the movies and the
reason why is because it's julia louise
dreyfus right she's a huge name even if
she's largely known in her tv roles
right playing elaine and seinfeld
playing in veep you know she's largely
been
a tv show person but having her in the
mcu i think they're going to put her in
the movies and even if she's not
necessarily in the movies what we do
know is that feigning in them
want to have the movies and the tv shows
cross over and so i think she'll be
probably the first character that we
ever really see that will kind of
operate behind the scenes going forward
and we'll see her sort of in the movies
and the tv shows right so like imagine
for example that not really even loki
like imagine that we get like punisher
where we get like a punisher tv show and
we saw her in some marvel cinematic
universe movie where she did something
and then her thread continued on in the
tv show the only issue you have with
that is feige and them said they didn't
want the tv shows or didn't want the
movies to rely on the tv shows so i
think whatever plot threads you see or
whatever stories you see taking place in
the marvel cinematic universe regarding
the tv show stuff is not really gonna be
play like a huge role in the movies
right i think the tv shows will be more
of like a
compliment to the movies but they won't
be required reading right like you know
to understand what's going on in new
avengers the movie you have to go back
and watch you know falcon winter soldier
i don't think it's really gonna be that
way it'll help but it won't be required
having said that
we know that at the end of the episode
that valerie basically snatched up uh
john walker right officially brought him
in as the us
agent now here's the thing that's kind
of crazy about this on one hand
there's all kinds of possibilities with
the concept of like contessa is
technically what her name is but the
reality is i think there's only really
one
only one real tangible explanation for
what's going on here i think that
contessa is a stand-in for valerie
cooper
in the marvel cinematic universe and i
think she's forming the commission on
superhuman activities i think that's
what's i think that's what we're getting
i think that's actually what's happening
here uh and here's the reason why i say
that the commission on superhero human
activities particularly was involved
with john walker
that there was a point in marvel comics
when the red skull was actually
manipulating the commission behind the
scenes and essentially got steve rogers
ousted as captain america and john
walker took his place that's when john
walker went from being like the super
patriot when he was initially introduced
to becoming the replacement captain
america and then ultimately was too
extreme
lost the lost the title and it was given
back to steve rogers again right so the
commission was just like oops
sorry guys and then of course when red
skull's actions were revealed it all
kind of reconciled everything but the
important thing here
is that with this particular set of
events right valerie cooper in marvel
comics was
hugely important and she's one of those
names that like nobody really knows but
her role
is immense she's in she's been in pretty
much everything right she's she was
behind the scenes if it had to do
with in any form or fashion curtailing
and even in some ways
getting in the way of super superhumans
not even just mutants but like super
powered beings superheroes she was
behind the scenes right she's the one
who spearheaded the commission on
superhuman activities she's the one that
basically helped us to spearhead and
launch
project wide awake like she's really the
ones kind of behind all that stuff now
here's the thing if the commission on
superhuman activities exists
and in turn you know val you know val is
more or less valerie cooper in the
marvel cinematic universe then it would
stand to reason
that u.s agent is going to be part of
freedom force so here's the thing
freedom force was kind of like the
the law enforcement apparatus behind the
commission on superhuman activities
because it was one thing to be a
government-sanctioned organization or
governmental entity and to kind of be
positioned as a way
to ensure that superheroes did what they
were supposed to it's another thing to
be able to actually enforce it now in
the comics
technically speaking freedom force was
mystique and her brotherhood of evil
mutants who were looking to basically
receive pardons for the the evil acts
they committed and then in turn they
were kind of brought in by the
commission
rebranded into freedom force and then
they were promised pardons if they
fulfilled their contracts right so of
course mystique and them don't really
exist in the mcu if they do exist we
haven't seen them yet uh so it'd be very
very
easy for for marvel to kind of take the
notion of freedom force and to make it
into what is in effect the long arm of
the law
quote unquote for the commission on
superhuman activities and for john
walker to be part of the team whether
he'll lead it i don't really know
but i think what you're seeing here in
the tv side of things
is this kind of situation where they're
going through and they're basically
recruiting people and so i wouldn't be
surprised if at the end of loki val
appears again
and val is like hey loki like i want to
bring you in right because one of the
things about the marvel cinematic
universe that you've probably picked up
already is that they're nothing if not
consistent almost dogmatic in how they
do things technically you don't really
do the same gag twice but tony stark
recruited the avengers how how
interesting would it be
if valerie cooper or if val was
basically valerie cooper and was
recruiting freedom force
recruiting people to basically work
alongside the government now why loki
would do that i'm not entirely sure we
don't really know
anything about the loki series outside
of the fact that it involves a time
variance authority which is a
wholly different beast in terms of
trying to understand that the time
variance authority is cool but they're
really more of a comic representation of
like bureaucracy and the government
nothing ever really seems to get done
but having said that the series itself
was interesting right i enjoyed the
series it left a lot of questions
unanswered and a lot of potential plot
threads that could be answered in the
future and i think that was important i
think one of the worst things a marvel
cinematic universe could have done with
falcon in the winter soldier was to wrap
it all up and leave
questions answered and the reason i say
that is because if you look at that show
and you go forward in the mcu people
want to see things build it's what made
the marvel cinematic universe successful
in the first place right not in the
sense that there were a bunch of
questions that were unanswered in iron
man but in a sense that like you saw
captain america shield in an iron man
movie right you you saw thor's hammer
land in new mexico at the end of a movie
where you just kind of saw that happen
continually events would take place in
little moments what happened in movies
that would tie into other movies and it
would all kind of
unify it and bring it all together
that's exactly what they're doing with
the tv side and i think it's a genius
idea
to do that so have you said that falcon
of the winter soldier was it a great
show
it was fun but it was cool it's not the
strongest outing so far one division
still ranks number one as far as the
disney plus shows but we're only two and
i do have a feeling loki is gonna blow
the doors off i feel like loki is gonna
be
amazing just looking at it it looks like
it's just gonna be absolutely awesome
hopefully it is i don't know if that's
true or not it could be that loki's like
the first big flop of disney i don't
think that's gonna happen
i think there's just too much talent
behind the scenes running the show but
regardless of how you slice it talking
to the winter soldier
was a fun show it was the closest thing
they've done to an actual movie in a tv
series uh but it was cool but that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end i'm looking forward to the next two
weeks we have a two week break and then
loki starts
so uh yeah we will catch you all later
peace